je donne maintenant la parole aux
représentants de la république
bolivarienne du venezuela afin qu'elle
présente la déclaration du chef d'état
j'arrive à six assaillants poursuivi
merci beaucoup monsieur le président au
nom de la république bolivarienne du
venezuela j'ai l'honneur de présenter le
message du président de la république
bolivarienne du venezuela nicolás maduro
moros je vous remercie
monsieur le secrétaire général antonio
guterres s mesdames et messieurs les
chefs d'état et de gouvernement mesdames
et messieurs les participants à cette
75e 1 session de l'assemblée générale
des nations unies je tiens d'abord à
vous demander de m'excuser de retirer
mon masque masse que nécessaire en cette
époque de pandémie et je tiens à
adresser mes salutations à tous ceux et
celles qui nous écoutent de par le monde
permettez moi de vous féliciter monsieur
le président au nom du gouvernement
constitutionnel du venezuela et du
peuple de notre république bolivarienne
félicitations pour votre désignation à
la présidence de cette 75e session de
l'assemblée générale
cette occasion est extrêmement
importante étant donné la situation
exceptionnelle que l'humanité traverse
du fait de cette urgence mondiale créée
par l'aco vite 19 jeudi exceptionnelle
car en plus de supposées des difficultés
sérieuses pour le complexe ordre
planétaire elle est pourtant une
occasion de réfléchir et de promouvoir
un changement de paradigme que
l'humanité elle même et surtout la
grande majorité de ceux qui vivent dans
la pauvreté l'exclusion as espère temps
de nous et des dirigeants de ce monde
dans cette même assemblée générale en
2001 notre commandant éternelle au goût
de chaves disais et je cite nous venons
donc sans crainte vous avec une grande
foi un grand optimisme dans la vie on la
fera taire
ite ans l'union la possibilité suprême
que nous avons aujourd'hui nous
dirigeants des pays de la planète de
chercher et de construire de vraies
solutions aux problèmes réels de quête
de justice et de paix au venezuela
nous croyons qu'il faut revoir
entièrement le monde à la loupe
comme le disait le commandant chavez une
loupe grossissante car le monde va mal
il ne cesse pas de trébucher d'erreurs
en erreurs
en cette année 2001 le commandant chavez
lancé un appel un appel à prendre
conscience de la réalité dans la
refondation de l'organisation des
nations unies et nous voici en 2020
insistant sur cette nécessité de
renouveler les paradigmes le venezuela
reconnaît que l'organisation des nations
unies depuis 75 ans a beaucoup apporté à
l'humanité
cependant nous exigeons davantage de
volonté plus d'efforts pour préserver
les acquis pour avancer sur la voie de
nouveaux objectifs nous insistons sur la
nécessité de renforcer la coopération
sud-sud de créer des mécanismes
alternatifs de financement et de soutien
technique qui encourage les initiatives
et les priorités définies par nos
peuples
pour atteindre les objectifs de
développement durable
il s'agit d'une tâche ponctuelles et
impérieuse chaque jour compte le sud
pense lui aussi le sud compte lui aussi
le sud existe lui aussi comme l'aurait
dit le grand poète benedetti dont nous
célébrons cette année le centenaire
nous devons tous oeuvrer pour sauver
notre planète nous lançons un appel à un
plus haut degré d'engagement politique
pour combattre les changements
climatiques qui sont une réalité pour
combattre les changements climatiques en
tant que priorité urgente
nous sommes conscients de l'importance
de renforcer les actions d'atténuation
et d'adaptation
conformément à la convention cadre des
nations unies sur les changements
climatiques et à l'accord de paris nous
réaffirmons donc l'importance des moyens
de mise en oeuvre pour que les pays en
développement puissent mener à bien
leurs actions climatiques noam chomsky
le disait récemment il ne nous reste
plus beaucoup de temps
monsieur le président les nations unies
et l'humanité tout entière sont
confrontés à une crise profonde et
complexe qui combine la pandémie de kobe
19 et défis mondiaux liés au changement
climatique et au développement durable
à ce tableau inquiétant vient s'ajouter
la non moins alarmantes prétention de
grande puissance qui entendent mener
l'humanité à une confrontation directe
dans le domaine militaire
ce pourrait être la dernière pour notre
espèce les états unis d'amérique
loin de jouer à un rôle de chef de file
positif ou proactif adopte un
comportement imprévisible avec un
gouvernement intransigeant ennemis de la
diplomatie de la haute politique qui
méprisent ouvertement le
multilatéralisme et toutes sortes de
règles mondiales préexistantes
la pandémie de kobe de 19 a rebattu les
cartes modifiées l'a priori les
priorités de toute l'humanité
étant donné ses conséquences sur la vie
humaine la pandémie a mises à nu les
inégalités dont pâtit le monde en les
aggravant malheureusement certaines
mesures d'urgence prises face à
l'épidémie n'ont fait qu'exacerber les
brèches sociales et économiques à
l'intérieur des pays c'est la raison
pour laquelle la communauté
internationale
dans son ensemble doit apporter une
réponse mondiale et coordonnée qui
permettra de soutenir toutes les nations
dans le besoin contribuant ainsi à créer
les conditions propices à l'apparition
d' économie plus forte et de société
plus inclusive
avant même la pandémie de kovy 19
l'effondrement de l'ordre géopolitique
ge conomique international était en
cours cependant cette urgence nous a
fait prendre conscience de la nécessité
de penser manière critique aux
contradictions du capitalisme à son
incapacité logique et opérationnel à
faire face à ces crises bien souvent les
états ont été réduits à leur plus simple
expression
le néolibéralisme imposé à étouffer les
institutions publiques transformant les
droits du peuple en service privé
transformant la santé en un produit de
luxe
écoutons dans les rues du monde la furie
des peuples qui se sentent orphelins et
désemparé la santé et le bien-être de la
population ne sont pas des marchandises
le marché ne peut pas continuer de
réglementer le destin de l'humanité le
venezuela considère que le rôle de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé doit
être un exemple de multilatéralisme qui
doit être renforcée l'organisation
mondiale de la santé doit être une
organisation qui agit et parle
fidèlement sans céder aux pressions sans
céder au chantage et aux attaques des
puissants une organisation qui confirme
son autorité morale
sa capacité scientifique et la
coopération fondée sur la solidarité
nous saluons les efforts énormes
déployés par les scientifiques des pays
soeur des pays frères que sont la russie
la chine et cuba
pour m
un vaccin efficace sur contre la copie
de 19 et nous sommes convaincus que ces
découvertes seront considérés comme un
bien public mondial par chacune de nos
nations en accès libre pour tous les
peuples du monde sans discrimination tel
est le voeu que nous que nous formulons
la république bolivarienne du venezuela
se propose de créer un fonds d'achat et
de marchés publics à fond tournon au
sein du système des nations unies pour
garantir l'accès aux denrées
alimentaires aux produits sanitaires un
fonds qui serait financée par des
ressources publiques
ceci permettrait de faire face à la
discrimination et au blocus économique
imposé à certains pays en facilitant
l'acquisition par les gouvernements des
biens et services nécessaires
nous lançons un appel à renforcer les
politiques et les fonds de financement
axé sur le développement des chaînes de
production locale et de nouveaux acteurs
économiques ainsi axée sur la création
d'une bande de technologies libres et
des processus universel de formation
la république bolivarienne du venezuela
plaide pour l'adoption d'un instrument
international juridiquement contraignant
sur le développement et le droit au
développement qui renforce la lutte des
peuples pour sortir de la pauvreté et
des inégalités sociales et en faveur de
la justice sociale
notre réélection en tant que membre du
conseil des droits de l'homme de
l'organisation des nations unies au
terme d'un vote souverain est
majoritaire des pays représentés au sein
du système des nations unies en dépit
des attaques incessantes de l'empiré
étasunien et de ses satellites
notre élection disait jarre réaffirmer
notre engagement de promouvoir le
respect des droits humains
et des libertés fondamentales de toutes
les personnes sans distinction aucune
de manière juste et équitable en
soutenant fermement toute initiative de
lutte contre les discriminations
ethniques basées sur le genre la
nationalité et les autres formes
d'intolérance qui sont liés nous sommes
attachés à la défense des principes
d'universalité d'impartialité
d'objectivité de non politisation et de
non sélectivité dans leurs applications
nous sommes engagés en faveur d'un
dialogue international interculturel
constructif et coopératif pour
encourager la promotion la protection de
tous les droits humains y compris bien
entendu le droit au développement
intégral des peuples
monsieur le président la république
bolivarienne du venezuela réaffirme son
attachement au règlement pacifique des
différends
conformément aux principes contenus dans
la charte des nations unies et ainsi
s'agissant du différend territorial
portant sur la gouaille à nice et qui
vaut le venezuela réaffirmé son respect
le plus strict de l'accord de genève de
1966 nous soulignons tout
particulièrement l'objet le but est la
raison d'être de l'accord de genève
cet accord donne clairement mandat pour
parvenir à une solution pratique
satisfaisante et acceptable pour les
deux parties
au travers des mécanismes successifs
prévu à l'article 33 de la charte des
nations unies
c'est au travers d'une négociation
politique diplomatique sur la base d'un
accord mutuel que nous parviendrons à
régler ce contentieux héritées du
colonialisme impérial
monsieur le président le monde
continue d'être le théâtre de nombreuses
injustices subies par des peuples
innocents menacés d'extermination
les le théâtre d'actions d'état
injustifiés et inadmissibles elles sont
la honte de l'humanité
une fois encore nous réaffirmons notre
appui et notre solidarité aux peuples
arabes de palestine ou nous exigeons le
respect de son territoire historique
établi en 1967 par cette organisation
des nations unies
nous soutenons l'appel des nations unies
pour que cesse l'infâme blocus blocus
criminel qui dure depuis près de 60 ans
contre le peuple frère de cuba et dans
ce sens nous réaffirmons l'appel au
gouvernement des etats-unis à lever
immédiatement le blocus économique
commercial et financier imposé à notre
nation soeur monsieur le président la
république bolivarienne du venezuela et
affirme son attachement à la promotion
et au renforcement du dialogue et de la
coopération
en jetant des ponts entre les peuples en
respectant les différences culturelles
et religieuses au travers de la
prévention des conflits par la
réconciliation et l'édification de la
paix le mouvement des pays non alignés a
promu la reconnaissance de ces
initiatives de ces politiques de ces
valeurs avec la célébration de la
journée internationale du
multilatéralisme et de la paix il a
rejoint le groupe des amis de l'alliance
des civilisations des nations unies qui
brandissent les drapeaux du pluralisme
et de l'équité il reste beaucoup à faire
certes nous agirons monsieur le
président le venezuela comme vous le
savez est la cible d'une attaque
constante notre patrie tenté mais est
victime d'une attaque multiformes de la
part de l' empire étasunien dans le
domaine
médiatique aux plans politique
économique
nous avons même été menacé d'une
agression militaire directe les mesures
unilatérales imposées par le
gouvernement des états unis d'amérique
avait pour but de faire plier les
vénézuéliens et les vénézuéliennes
mais notre peuple aux côtés de son
gouvernement constitutionnel a opposé
une résistance héroïque à l'opprobre à
l'illégalité à l'inhumanité d'un empire
qui représente aujourd'hui la plus grave
menace qui pèse sur le monde
pluripolaire et multicentrique
aujourd'hui debout avec la dignité d'un
peuple fils des gloires du libérateur
libertador simon bolivar nous disons au
gouvernement supprime à site des états
unis que le monde les regarde que des
millions d'yeux au 21ème siècle voit au
delà de ce que disent les médias
il est encore temps de revenir à la
légalité internationale
nous leur disons qu'il est encore temps
d'inverser ce discrédit ce malaise
global que leur arbitraire et leur
arrogance provoque dans le monde
conscient d'aujourd'hui poursuivre la
ville et violation de la charte des
nations unies les conduira
inexorablement à l' isolement au
discrédit à la condamnation par
l'histoire des peuples y compris pour
leurs propres citoyens le peuple des
états-unis qui est descendue dans la rue
pour protester contre le racisme contre
la brutalité policière et contre les
abus les mesures coercitives
unilatérales ont suscité non seulement
l'indignation et le rejet des peuples
entre la prétendue dictature mondiale
brandi depuis les etats-unis et nature
qu'il tente de nous imposer
mais elles ont aussi suscité la cohésion
et des initiatives nationales autour de
nouvelles formes de
production de solutions techniques et
technologiques la créativité a été la
réponse apportée à la persécution dont
des victimes notre industrie nationale
le vrai vénézuélien la vraie
vénézuélienne de chair et de sang sont
ainsi ils ont tant voulu les occulter
les méprise et aujourd'hui je peux vous
dire excellence que dans notre patrie
s'est déclenché une révolution de
l'innovation une nouvelle offensive pour
transformer en cercle vertueux de
débouchés ces tentatives d'agression
pour pousser notre nation dans l'abyme
nous avons accompli des efforts
titanesques avec nos propres capacités
en plus de la solidarité de la
coopération de pays amis et du système
des nations unies pour faire face à la
pandémie de kobe 19 nous avons évité le
pire en dépit des pronostics des plans
et des voeux catastrophiste
catastrophique de ceux qui nous
agressent ni le blocus illégal ni les
agressions contre notre gouvernement ne
nous ont détourné ni empêché d'atteindre
au prix de grands efforts notre objectif
à savoir protéger la vie de notre
population
aujourd'hui nous pouvons dire que nous
avons effectué environ un million deux
cent mille tests gratuits ce qui
représente à ce jour en moyenne 60 2482
test par million d'habitants nous
pouvons dire que nous sommes le pays
d'amérique latine et des caraïbes qui a
réalisé le plus de tests nous le disons
avec humilité en formulant le voeu de
pouvoir toujours aider les pays voisins
dont nous recevons bien souvent de la
part de leur gouvernement uniquement des
agressions ceci est une vérité sur le
venezuela que vous non
andré ni ne lirez jamais dans les médias
traditionnels
encore moins sur les réseaux sociaux ou
sur internet
le blocus vise aussi les moyens de
communication c'est pour cette raison
que je tenais à partager avec vous notre
expérience parce qu'elle pourrait sauver
des vies ailleurs dans le monde comme
l'expérience de la chine de cuba et de
la russie l'ont fait pour nous notre
système de protection sociale et de
santé nous permet d'aller de maison en
maison à la recherche des cas positifs
de prendre en charge les cas suspects où
les cas potentiels
nous comptons sur ce système sur les
missions médicales sur le système
automatisé de protection baptisé sistema
patriat où sont inscrits plus de 20
millions de citoyens âgés notamment sur
une population de 30 millions
d'habitants ce qui équivaut comme vous
l'aurez constaté à plus de deux tiers la
population ce système nous a permis
d'atteindre toutes les communautés dans
notre pays nous sommes dotés d'un modèle
propre et élaboré dans le but d'accorder
la priorité à la vie de chacun et de
chacune sur un pied d'égalité
grâce à lui nous avons ensemble maintenu
les distances sanitaires et la vie
productive du pays
ce système nous l'avons baptisé de set
par set
nous le mettons à la disposition de
toutes les nations avec la modestie qui
nous caractérise
sept jours une semaine de confinement
dans les foyers quarantaine stricte et
sept jours une semaine de souplesse
économique large généralisée ceci a
permis d'instaurer une nouvelle
normalité
en attendant de pouvoir venir à bout de
cette pandémie
notre gouvernement s'est préparé pour
affronter ce défi avec notre peuple nous
nous avons atteint un degré de
conscience supérieure avec la population
vénézuélienne et grâce à l'efficacité de
notre système de santé publique
c'est ainsi que nous avons pu contrôler
les premiers assauts de cette pandémie
qui a mis le monde à genoux en gagnant
du temps pour améliorer les protocoles
de prévention de traitement de
protection de notre peuple
le venezuela est l'un des rares pays à
offrir des traitements gratuits et
différenciés aux personnes touchées
asymptomatiques présentant des symptômes
légers modérée ou grave
notre politique de prévention et de
prise en charge passe par une
hospitalisation systématique de tous les
cas positifs même lorsqu'ils sont
asymptomatiques
ceci a permis d'éviter une expansion
exponentielle de la maladie monsieur le
président la république bolivarienne du
venezuela a été dépouillé de plus de 30
milliards de dollars
je les séquestrés sur des comptes
bancaires aux états unis et en europe de
même toute entreprise
tout gouvernement qui ferait commerce
avec notre pays qu'il s'agisse de biens
de services quels qu'ils soient aliments
médicaments ou combustibles ou encore
additifs nécessaires à la production
d'essence l'essence dans notre peuple a
besoin
ces entreprises et gouvernements sont
poursuivis la raison pour laquelle nous
répétons devant le monde que le
venezuela s'est préparée à résister à
cette offensive
cette agression criminelle et inhumaine
et nous résistons le venezuela s'est
préparé pour triompher de ce blocus
imposé par le gouvernement des états
unis d'amérique
nous livrons là une bataille pour la
paix pour notre patrie pour la région
pour l'humanité tout entière
notre peuple le venezuela héroïque
à part le passé à assumer le rôle
historique qui lui et revenait devant
l'ignominie de lempire le plus dangereux
de l'histoire universelle un empire qui
à son tour est en train d'écrire
les chapitres les plus atroces
d'inhumanité et d'actions criminelles le
monde doit savoir que nous sommes prêts
à les combattre avec la force de notre
histoire de notre esprit de la raison et
du droit international je tiens à
rappeler une fois encore combien nous
sommes reconnaissants des déclarations
temps du secrétaire général que de la
haute commissaire aux droits de l'homme
michelle bachelet qui ont demandé la
levée immédiate des mesures coercitives
unilatérales et criminels qui sont non
seulement contraires à la charte des
nations unies mais qui constituent aussi
des obstacles évident pour les pays
concernés des obstacles qui les
empêchent de lutter comme il se doit
contre la pandémie de covile 19 et le
réaliser les objectifs de développement
durable
ces attaques comme vous le savez ne se
limite pas aux simples mesures
coercitives unilatérales le 3 mai
dernier le venezuela a fait face à une
tentative d'incursion maritime d'un
groupe de mercenaires et des terroristes
financés par le gouvernement des états
unis et entraîné sur le territoire de la
colombie avec l'appui total et absolu
des gouvernements des états unis et de
colombie ce groupe de terroristes nous
nous y sommes confrontés en temps réel
par le biais de l'union civique aux
militaires policières nous avons pu
neutraliser capturer les auteurs de
cette attaque de cette incursion armée
aujourd'hui il se trouve à la
disposition des institutions
judiciaire en vue de leur procès nous
avons aussi récemment capturé un espion
des états unis qui transportait des
armes de guerre et des documents
concernant notre industrie pétrolière et
électriques
ce harcèlement et quotidien nous y
sommes confrontés et nous l'avons
affronté des jouets dénoncé des masques
et à chaque fois je me demande que dire
d'une action terroriste posée alors que
nous vivons des circonstances
extraordinaires à savoir la pandémie de
comics 19 comment l'humanité peut être
qualifié ce type d'attitude nous pouvons
dire à tout le moins que la démesure
s'est imposée plus terrible des péchés
semble posséder aujourd'hui entièrement
les élites des états unis c'est la
raison pour laquelle la république
bolivarienne du venezuela réitère la
nécessité de revendiquer les principes
de respect de la souveraineté d'auto
remise détermination des peuples tels
que consacrés dans la charte des nations
unies qui nous unit tous dont la
violation illégale par certains états
membres de l'organisation pour des
raisons ignoble met en danger la
stabilité de notre pays et de la région
de l'amérique latine et des caraïbes les
pays épris de paix doivent absolument
agir et faire comprendre au gouvernement
des états unis que au milieu d'une
pandémie mondiale personne ne comprend
personne ne peut s'expliquer la
recrudescence des actes de persécution
criminelle
le renforcement du blocus contre des
pays nobles tels que cuba le nicaragua
le venezuela la série et d'autres pays
frère du monde
nous devons exiger que cessent toutes
les mesures coercitives unilatérales que
soit levé toutes les soi disant sens
action que nos peuples soient libres
d'exercer leurs droits leurs droits au
développement et à la paix les
etats-unis et leurs gouvernements
doivent se départir de ses pratiques
d'antan consistant à criminaliser ceux
qui ne se soumettent pas à leur dessein
dans ce monde et qui maintiennent comme
nous une politique d'indépendance et de
souveraineté les états unis il nous faut
le dire sont devenus au cours de
l'histoire la menace la plus
significative sur la paix mondiale
nous tenons à faire nôtre les paroles du
secrétaire général des nations unies
antonio goûter rech
au sujet du cessez le feu de la
cessation des conflits dans le monde
en réaffirmant le respect sans
restriction et le la pleine adhésion aux
objectifs et aux buts de la charte des
nations unies et du droit international
en particulier le respect de la
souveraineté de l'intégrité territoriale
et de la non ingérence dans les affaires
intérieures des états principe du
dialogue entre les nations
le règlement pacifique des différends et
l'interdiction de la menace ou de
l'emploi de la force
monsieur le président le venezuela a
toujours été un pays d'accueil de
réfugiés de migrants cependant
conséquence directe des mesures
coercitives unilatérales criminels et
des agressions économiques imposées par
le gouvernement des états unis à notre
peuple un processus de migration de
citoyens vénézuéliens a été déclenché
essentiellement pour des raisons
économiques
cependant actuellement notre pays est
confronté à une vague de retours
volontaires de retour massif de milliers
de migrants vénézuélien en provenance de
pays affichant de très des taux très
élevé de contamination lakovic 19 tels
que la colombie l'équateur le pérou le
chili le brésil
en raison en premier lieu de l'échec de
la gestion de la commune 19 dans ces
pays
deuxièmement la violation systématique
des droits humains des migrants
vénézuélien les politiques à la
chronique et xénophobes contre les
migrants de notre pays même dans les
plus hautes sphères gouvernementales de
ces pays la discrimination les mauvais
traitements les mauvaises conditions
socio-économiques les situations de semi
esclavage la traite d'êtres humains les
calamités subis par nos migrants en
violation manifeste de leur dignité
humaine eh bien quelle a été la réaction
du monde
nous nous interrogeons qui se dit
préoccupé par le venezuela devant ces
faits condamnables
le silence est complice
comme nous l'avons dit la pandémie de
colis de 19 à catalyser les conditions
de vie déjà insoutenable de milliers de
migrants dans les pays dits d'accueil
qui nous ont dit que l'augmentation de
la bande au le manque de réponse le
manque d'attention de la part des
autorités de ces pays sont pas tant la
fragilité des systèmes de protection
sociale de ces pays présenté parfois
comme des modèles économiques et sociaux
a été ainsi mis en évidence une fois
encore nous nous interrogeons comment
cela est-il possible
malgré les sommes de dollars octroyés à
ces gouvernements au terme d'
extravagante conférence de promesses de
dons pour les migrants vénézuélien
qu'ont ils fait de cet argent les
gouvernements l'ont ils volent et nous
pensons qu'il faut indéniablement et tu
dis avec toute la rigueur
institutionnels et scientifiques le rôle
joué par certaines institutions ou
agences des nations unies où certaines
personnes appartenant à ces agences
notamment le haut commissariat aux
réfugiés où l'organisation
internationale des migrations
monsieur le président vous un souci de
réconciliation et conformément aux
accords conclus le cadre du dialogue
national entre les forces politiques de
nuit là en septembre 2019 un ensemble de
mesures ont été adoptées pour garantir
la démocratie au venezuela
récemment ont été graciés sont dits
citoyens appartenant à des groupes de la
droite d'opposition poursuivi pour
différents délits impliquant des
agressions contre notre pays
grâce à cette décision nous voulons
poursuivre la voie de la réconciliation
la voie de la réconciliation nationale
sachant que la paix mérite tous les
efforts et nous ne cesserons pas
monsieur le président de poursuivre ses
efforts conformément au mandat contenu
dans notre constitution nationale
approuvée par le peuple vénézuélien par
référendum en décembre 1999 aura lieu le
dimanche 6 décembre prochain la 25e
élections démocratiques en 20 ans
cette fois il s'agira de renouveler le
pouvoir législatif plus de 14 mille 400
candidats et candidates participeront
issus de plus de 107 organisations
politiques représentant tout le spectre
de des tendances idéologiques national
je peux vous dire qu'au venezuela il
existe toutes les garanties nécessaires
pour la tenue de ces élections
parlementaires nous avons pour cela
invité le monde à nous accompagner à
être le témoin de cette démocratie
vivante
rien ni personne ne pourra priver le
peuple du venezuela de son droit de se
choisir un nouveau pouvoir législatif
car celui ci est un instrument
fondamental de l'existence collective
est l'expression de la volonté du
pouvoir originel personne ne décident à
notre place
nous ne sommes jamais intervenu n'avons
pas l'intention d'intervenir
jamais dans les affaires d'autres
nations nous sommes respectueux et nous
exigeons donc d'être respectés en retour
mais malgré cela le gouvernement de
washington qui a conduit son propre
peuple à l'effondrement du fait de la
pandémie et qui d'ailleurs tiendra des
élections présidentielles en novembre
prochain en violation flagrante du droit
international a imposé illégalement de
nouvelles mesures coercitives
unilatérales contre les institutions
démocratiques du venezuela en
l'occurrence en l'occurrence le pouvoir
électoral dans une tentative de
s'immiscer dans la tenue des élections
parlementaires prévues par notre
constitution
c'est pourquoi la république
bolivarienne du venezuela réaffirme la
nécessité de revendiquer les principes
de respect de la souveraineté et de
l'autodétermination des peuples exprimé
dans la charte des nations unies
principe dans la violation illégale par
certains membres de l'organisation vise
à mener le veut le venezuela violence et
au conflit nous ne le permettrons pas
nous exigeons le respect le chemin du
village à la donner à la paix la
démocratie la liberté le vote la
participation avec le peuple comme
acteur principal
c'est ainsi que nous avons procédé par
le passé cet incident nous procéderons à
l'avenir monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les chefs d'état et de
gouvernement voici le venezuela debout
avec sa dignité historique amp est prête
à relever de nouveaux défis
prêt pour de nouvelles victoires je
prends congé en formulant le voeu que
règne la concorde de la paix la
coopération dans le monde entier je vous
remercie
[Rires]